so guys I'm in a restaurant I came to  you and what's this on the toilet how  does this work  doesn't make sense then I realize me to  myself which I'm gonna demonstrate now  why in Turkey has maybe I think zero one  case of the corona virus check this out  so you come to the loo  we've got this plastic laying around up  of all right last time also you've got  the boots at him as well guys can you  know anyway the story so we have this  here on so you spot your hands and once  you do this whatever so the reason why  do not you guys Turkish people have been  a genie a lot of people are but just  saying you know you all make sense now  why there's no coronavirus but anyways  hygiene that's a part of being a Muslim  you know do an ablution five times a day  cleaning yourself is very very important  and copy in your face you know they make  happen but all the countries had now  they're implementing you notice or than  any policy but anyways I enjoyed that do  you